[Music]
[Applause]
It is Well to reflect that the
Wilderness furnishes perhaps the best
opportunity for Pure aesthetic
enjoyment this requires that beauty be
observed as a
unity and that for the brief duration of
any pure aesthetic
experience the cognition of The observed
object must completely fill the
spectator's
cosmos there can be no extraneous
thoughts no question about the creator
of the phenomenon its structure
what it resembles or what vanity in the
beholder it
gratifies the purely aesthetic Observer
has for the moment forgotten his own
soul he has only one sensation left and
that is
[Music]
exquisiteness in the wilderness with its
entire freedom from the manifestations
of human
[Music]
will that perfect objectivity which is
essential for Pure aesthetic
Rapture can probably be achieved more
readily than among any other forms of
[Music]
[Applause]
beauty
[Music]
here
[Applause]
[Music]